[Musik]
[Applaus]
habt ihr diese Bilder gesehen nun solche
schicken Wolkenkratzer und
glitzerfassaden könnten heute in Buenos
Aires stehen wie gesagt könnten es kam
zum Leidwesen viele Argentinien nämlich
ganz anders Ende des 18 und Anfang des
19 Jahrhunderts war Buenos Aires
Hauptstadt des vizekönigreichs Rio de la
Plata im Juni 1806 wurde sie von den
Engländern eingenommen diese wurden aber
nach ein paar Monaten wieder vertrieben
im darauffolgenden Jahr passierte das
gleiche noch einmal mit dem gleichen
Ergebnis und die Argentinier Scherzen
bis heute dass ihr Land ohne die
Befreiung von den Engländern heute wie
Australien aussehen könnte nämlich
genauso wohlhabend und reich mit Städten
wie wir sie eben gesehen haben
natürlich werden wir nie wissen wie es
wirklich gekommen wäre und das ist
argentin heute schlechter geht als
Australien darüber haben wir schon
einige Videos gedreht die ich euch
verlinke einen Punkt haben wir bislang
aber ausgelassen man mag es kaum glauben
aber argentinien war mal ein mega
reiches Land vielleicht sogar das
reichste der damaligen Welt im heutigen
Video gehen wir daher der interessanten
Frage nach wie es ausgerechnet dieses
Land am anderen Ende der Welt zu so
großen Wohlstand gebracht hat und
vielleicht auch wie es möglich war das
ist aus diesem wolligen Höhen auf jenes
elende Niveau Abstürzen konnte von denen
es heute einfach nicht mehr hochkommt
wir legen gleich los nach einer kurzen
Botschaft unseres tollen Sponsors
surfshark der dieses Video möglich
gemacht hat denn surfshark hat auch ein
VPN im Angebot das wirklich
empfehlenswert und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so laut ist z.B
selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kann ein
Wäsche piratet Network VPN einen nicht
vor allem Gefahren schützen die
netzlauer man muss nach wie vor
unsichthalten lassen Unwissen was man
tut aber es stellt hier für ein Werkzeug
mir gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen
verfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheit Features könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit dem integrierten klimberg das
alle unerwünschten Cookies und Papa
blockt weiterer Vorteil eines dass sie
so tun könnt als während ihr in einem
anderen Ort suchen
nicht verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt Zensur und
geoblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes dringend nur in den USA Anbieten
von Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem und das ist noch
lange nicht alles denn mit nur einem
surfshark konnte wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt ihr von surfshark auch
noch ein Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und um
deine ersten drei Monate gratis dazu den
Link zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nicht viel los besorgt damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzielle die Arme
das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe des Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung bei den damit hätten sie
in Zukunft noch mehr und noch bessere
Videos zu liefern so und nun stellt euch
alle wir begeben uns auf einer Reise ins
Südamerika das 18 Jahrhundert
die schwere Geburt einer Nation
Ende des 18 Jahrhunderts beschloss die
spanische Krone das Vizekönigreich Rio
de la Plata zu gründen es hieß deswegen
Vizekönig Reich weil der Regent nicht in
Südamerika war sondern in Spanien ein
Vizekönig musste die Krone also vor Ort
vertreten bei dem Gebiet handelt es sich
um eine abgelegene und dünn besiedelte
Region im Norden des heutigen
Argentiniens es umfasst aber auch Teile
der heutigen Länder Uruguay Bolivien und
Paraguay Aussicht der Spanier war die
Region damals nicht besonders wichtig es
wirkte wie ein Anhängsel des spanischen
weltreises aber das änderte sich mit der
Zeit denn auch Portugal expandierte von
Brasilien aus in diese Region zu den
Kriegen zahlreiche englische Schmuggler
dort ihr Unwesen und so wie eben
manchmal Konkurrenz das Geschäft belebt
wuchs auch das spanische Interesse an
seine vernachlässigen Territorium die
Spanier beschlossen also eine stärkere
Präsenz in der Region aufzubauen wobei
das eher ein letztes Aufbäumen
darstellte denn das spanische Weltreich
lag damals bereits im Sterben es war
wirtschaftlich am Ende und das
Mutterland durch Napoleons Truppen
besetzt die Ideen der Aufklärung von re
Region und Freiheit verbreiteten sich
auch in Südamerika zwischen 1810 und
1825 gab es im praktisch allen
amerikanischen Territorien des Reiches
Unabhängigkeitsbewegungen mit lediglich
zwei Ausnahmen und das waren
ausgerechnet Kuba und Puerto Rico zu den
aptourniergebieten gehörte auch das
heutige Argentinien dort setzte man am
25 Mai 1810 den Vizekönig Tesla Ross ab
und rief eine lokale Regierung aus der
offizielle Grund dafür war dass die
Kohle keine Macht mehr hatte denn der
spanische König war von Napoleon
gefangen genommen worden die Macht in
Rio de la Plaza sollte nun an das Volk
übergehen sechs Jahre später am 9 juli
1816 erklärte Argentinien seine
endgültige Unabhängigkeit doch das
brachte kaum Frieden ganz im Gegenteil
Krieg folgte auf Krieg um die Herrschaft
im Land es ging darum wer die Regierung
bildete wer Macht und Einfluss haben
würde im Grunde gab es zwei große
Fraktionen die unitarius und die
federales die ersten die unitarios waren
für einen zentralstand die föderales für
ein Bundesstaat mit eigenständigen
Provinzen die unitarius aus Buenos Aires
wollten dann macht der Hauptstadt im
Lande ausweiten denn diese kontrollierte
den Zoll und den Hafen und sie war das
wirtschaftliche Zentrum wo sich Geld und
Macht Balken folglich so die unitarius
sollte die zentrale auch mehr Rechte im
ganzen Land haben die Provinzen im
Landesinneren argumentierten aber dass
diese Ressourcen allen gehören würden
die Einnahmen aus dem Zoll und dem Hafen
sollten gleichmäßig verteilt werden
Sonderrechte sollte es keine geben auch
nicht für Buenos Aires der Konflikt zog
sich fast durch das ganze 19 Jahrhundert
1853 verabschiedete einen weitgehend
geeintes Argentinien seine Verfassung
ich sage deswegen weitgehend weil Buenos
Aires sich zunächst abspaltete die
Hauptstadt war damals das Comeback von
Buenos Aires kam erst 1880 dann aber
auch als Hauptstadt eines endlich
wirklich geeinten Argentiniens die
Staatsgründung Argentinien insgesamt
eine schwierige Geburt und ist fast
immer von eigenes Video für echte
Fenster argentinischen Geschichte in
unserem Zusammenhang ist folgendes
wichtig die Verfassung Argentiniens von
1853 war so etwas wieder zweite
gründungs des Landes nach der
Unabhängigkeit
[Musik]
von diesem Moment an begann der Aufbau
Argentiniens und die Gründung der
Institutionen die das Land von Grund auf
verändern sollten das ganze Land machte
sich es auf den Weg einer der reichsten
Orte der Welt zu werden und an dieser
Stelle taucht einer der wichtigsten
Namen der argentinischen Geschichte auf
Juan Bautista Alberti er gilt als Vater
der Verfassung Argentiniens er
veröffentlicht eine Schrift mit dem
Titel Grundlagen und Ausgangspunkte für
die politische Organisation der
argentinischen Republik Alberti entwirft
darin eine argentinische Verfassung in
ihren Grundzügen das macht ihn quasi zu
ihrem geistigen Schöpfer die
Ausarbeitung der einzelnen Gesetze in
einer verfassungsgebenden Versammlung
über diese anderen er hatte die
theoretischen Vorarbeit geleistet für
uns weil wir so altpolitik ist dieses
Werk Albert dies hoch interessant denn
es erklärt auch die Hindernisse mit den
Argentinien zu kämpfen hatte um sich zu
einem modernen Land zu entwickeln
[Musik]
Alberti erkannte folgende Probleme der
Entwicklung Argentiniens dem Land
mangelte es an Edelmetallen die etwa
Gold und Silber und es war nur dünn
besiedelt außerdem lag es soweit ab von
der entwickelten Welt in Europa was ist
deshalb brauchte so war ein politischer
Rahmen der den industriellen Fortschritt
möglich machen sollte alberty
identifizierte vier große Hindernisse
die überwunden werden mussten damit
Argentinien die Armut hinter sich lassen
und durchstarten konnte erstens der
Mangel an Kapital dass man zum
Investieren brauchte zweitens die
geringe Bevölkerungszahl argentinien
hatte zu dieser Zeit eine Bevölkerung
von kommt 2 Millionen Menschen ganze
Landstriche waren praktisch ungewohnt
problem Nummer drei war die fehlende
Infrastruktur was kein Wunder ist wenn
kaum jemand dort wohnt und man ist
Kapital nicht investiert wird es fehlte
dem Land außerdem an genügend
Rechtssicherheit was problem Nummer vier
darstellte ein modernes rechts-system
das privat Eigentum garantierte sowie
unternehmensfreiheit das alles war
damals im Land der Gauchos Fehlanzeige
kleine Anmerkung am Rande
auffälligerweise sind es doch immer
wieder dieselben Faktoren die über den
ökonomischen Erfolg und Misserfolg eines
Landes entscheiden Kapital Pflege
Menschen Infrastruktur und
Rechtssicherheit es ist fast wie eine
Schablone die damals passte und heute
auch noch passt leg diese Schablone
einfach mal über ein paar Länder eurer
Wahl wo diese Faktoren geht's bergab
aber zurück nach Argentinien die
Verfassung von 1853 Griff viele Gedanken
al Paradies auf es entstand eine
freiheitliche Verfassung der man die
Ähnlichkeit zu amerikanischen ansieht
sie garantierte fortan privat Eigentum
und die Freiheit des Einzelnen und sie
förderte freies Unternehmertum und
Länder die mit Freiheit waren zogen im
19 Jahrhundert leistungsfähige Menschen
magisch an das galt damals für die USA
und auch eben für Argentinien das Land
profitiert von Einwanderern die etwas
Neues schaffen wollten weil es den
kreativen und fleißigen Chancen bot und
ähnlich wie in den USA florierte auch in
Argentinien die Eisenbahn quasi die
Hightech-Branche des 19 Jahrhunderts der
erste Präsident 1863 bartholomä mitre
dann kam Domingo faustinos und dann
Nikolas Adrian und unter diesen drei
ersten Präsidenten und der neuen
Verfassung startete das Land in die
Moderne durch ab den 1880ern blühte es
förmlich auch von da an galt argentin
als vollständig befriedet die Stadt
Buenos Aires gliederte sich wieder an
und wurde Hauptstadt und Patagonien kam
vollständig dazu es begann das größte
Wirtschaftswachstum in der Geschichte
des Landes wir sprechen von einem
Prozess der mehr als 50 Jahre anhielt
die wirtschaftliche Blüte katapultierte
Argentinien im ersten Jahrzehnte 20
Jahrhunderts in die Top Ten der
reichsten und wohlhabendsten Länder der
Welt es war eine Erfolgsstory fast wie
in den USA so etwas wie das
südamerikanische Traum
[Musik]
das Land wuchs zu einem der weltweit
führenden Nahrungsmittelproduzenten
heran mit fast 12 Millionen Hektar
Anbaufläche 5 Millionen Tonnen
exportierten Getreide jährlich und
Millionen von Rindern und das meine
Lieben Zuschauer waren noch nicht alles
Argentinien schuf damals auch in der
modernsten Infrastrukturen der Welt mit
großen Häfen Straßenbahn in den Städten
und 28000 km Eisenbahnstrecken die durch
das ganze Land führten die Frage ist wie
hat es Argentinien geschafft einen
Aufstieg hinzulegen der mit dem der USA
vergleichbar ist wodurch wurde es
dermaßen Reich nun das alles sehen wir
uns jetzt im Detail an aufgepasst
ein Traumziel für ein neues Leben
[Musik]
man folgte alverdisprinzipien und
öffnete die Schleusen für massenhafte
Einwanderung dahinter stand die
Grundidee eine riesiges leeres Land neu
zu besiedeln und ein neues Leben
anzufangen zwischen dem Ende des 19 und
dem Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts kam
Millionen und Abermillionen Menschen
argentinien war damals nach den
Vereinigten Staaten des beliebteste Ziel
für Europäer es kamen Spanier Italiener
deutsche Griechen und eine Menge anderer
Völker im Jahr 1905 lag die Bevölkerung
bereits bei knapp 5,8 Millionen
Einwohner hat sechs Jahre später bei
fast 7 Millionen und warum gehst du nach
Argentinien naja so wie alle anderen um
zu sehen ob ich aus der Armut
herauskomme Dialog zwischen den
Professor für politisches recht alter
und einem spanischen Einwanderer im Jahr
1910 aber was hatte das Land denn zu
bieten nun neben einer Menge Arbeit gab
es auch viel höhere Gehälter
[Musik]
die Löhne der Einwanderer in Argentinien
waren dreimal so hoch wie in Spanien und
war doppelt so hoch wie in Italien
natürlich war nicht alles so wunderbar
die Arbeit war hart um das neue Leben in
der Fremde nicht einfach aber fleißige
Menschen die Chancen erkennen können
hält so etwas nicht ab vor allem wenn
man sieht dass es viele von ihnen
geschafft haben so überzeugten die
erfolgreichen Einwanderer auch ihr
Verwandten und Freunde in der Heimat die
Koffer zu packen und in den
argentinischen Traum zu ziehen und
dadurch ist die Bevölkerung des Landes
in die Höhe gestellt und schneller
gewachsen als in Ländern die Kanada oder
Australien diese waren ja damals
ebenfalls klassische Einwanderungsländer
seht euch an überrascht nun lasst uns
schnell weitermachen wenn sie noch lange
nicht fertig
[Musik]
der Aufschwung kommt auf Schienen
die Eisenbahn eroberte des Land sie
selbst stellte eine unvergleichbare
Boom-Branche da aber sie war auch
Treiber des Wachstums für andere
Branchen endlich konnten waren schnell
und billig transportiert werden hier war
wirklich notammern in Argentinien sehr
wenige Flüsse und waren zu
transportieren einen gut ausgebautes
Eisenbahn es war also die perfekte
Lösung zwischen 1865 und 1910 wuchs das
Schienennetz von rund 500 km auf mehr
als 30.000 km an diese Gleise verbannten
den Norden mit den Süden die anderen mit
dem Atlantik und die Pampa mit buenos
über dessen Hafen liefen damals fast 80%
des internationalen Handels des Landes
Note 10 war Argentinien die Nummer 10 in
der Welt was den Fortschritt bei der
Eisenbahn angeht beachtet dabei bitte
folgendes das argentinische Schienennetz
war im Verhältnis zur Landesfläche
größer als das in Kanada oder Australien
aber haltet euch jetzt gut fest die Air
Force Geschichte geht noch weiter
[Musik]
ein Land im Club der Topf verdienen
aus unserer heutigen Perspektive fällt
es manchmal schwer den Reichtum der
damaligen Länder realistisch
einzuschätzen aber was hilft ist ein
Vergleich nach Angaben des britischen
Ökonomen Endes Madison waren 1910 nur
sieben Länder auf der ganzen Welt
wohlhabender als Argentinien Belgien die
Schweiz Großbritannien sowie Kanada
Australien die Vereinigten Staaten und
Neuseeland ganz genau die Argentinier
waren damals möglicherweise wohlhabender
als die Deutschen in ihrem Kaiserreich
tatsächlich das dann für kurze Zeit am
1895 sogar als das reichste Land der
Welt das argentinische pro kopfeinkommen
war im Jahr 1919 z.B 50% höher als das
Italiens 180% höher als das Japans und
fast fünfmal höher als das ist
benachbarten Brasiliens und es gibt noch
mehr Daten im Jahr 1910 war argentin der
weltweit führende Exporteur von Weizen
Meister Rindfleisch scharf Fleisch und
wollen
zwischen 1900 und 1913 machten die
argentinischen Ausfuhren 2,1% aller
weltweiten Exporte aus im Vergleich dazu
hat er Australien im selben Zeitraum nur
einen Anteil von 1,5%. Argentinien hatte
damals um ein Drittel höhere Exporte als
Australien das heute so extrem reich ist
eines ist also klar Argentinien befand
sich damals in einem absoluten Höhenflug
die immensen Ressourcen des Landes
machten es zu einer Agrar macht die
Städte wuchsen unaufhörlich wie auch der
Dienstleistungssektor und die Industrie
und als ob das noch nicht genug gewesen
wäre gab es noch eine große Veränderung
die Argentinien auf die Weltspitze
brachte aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein Land lernt lesen
in der zweiten Hälfte des 19
Jahrhunderts unternahm Argentinien
enormer Anstrengungen im Bildungsbereich
es wurden hunderte von Schulen gegründet
und sogar Lehrer aus den USA geholt und
das war noch nicht alles 1882 er liest
Präsident Julio Roca das Gesetz 1.420
über die Grundschulbildung darin wurde
religionsfreie Schulbildung Pflicht und
die Schule war kostenlos es ist kein
Wunder dass plötzlich überall im
landschulen und leerinstitute entstanden
dadurch erhöhte sich die
Alphabetisierungsrate von rund 30% in
den 80ern auf über 80% im Jahr 1939
diese Zahl mag uns heute niedriger
erscheinen aber wir müssen bedenken über
welche Epoche wir sprechen während zum
Beispiel 1914 in Argentinien 35% der
Bevölkerung nicht lesen und schreiben
konnten waren es zur gleichen Zeit in
Spanien fast 60%
[Musik]
mit anderen Worten Argentinien wuchs in
der Produktion in der Bevölkerung in der
Infrastruktur und auch in der Bildung es
wuchs stärker als die europäischen
Länder vor allem seit ehemaliges
Mutterland und es wug schneller als die
große Mehrheit aller Länder der Welt
erinnert ihr euch noch an den Anfang des
Videos an diesen Scherz den Argentinier
über die Befreiung von Buenos Aires von
den Engländern machen zur damaligen Zeit
hätte dieser Witz überhaupt nicht
funktioniert er wäre völlig absolut
erschienen denn zu Beginn des 20
Jahrhunderts stand Argentinien auf
demselben Level wie Australien enthalten
sogar noch besser Buenos Aires war eine
Weltmetropole es war das Paris
Südamerikas doch leider hielt dieser
Wohlstand nicht lange an und hier denke
ich sagt ein Diagramm mehr als 1000
Worte seht euch an es ist wie ein längst
vergangener Traum diese goldenen Zeiten
Argentinien lang lang ist her aber
immerhin hat das ganze rund 100 Jahre
gedauert zuerst die Unabhängigkeit von
Spanien dann die politische Einigung das
Ringen um eine Verfassung und dann die
Blüte Phase bis in die erste Hälfte des
20 Jahrhunderts aber warum war der Traum
eigentlich plötzlich aus
[Musik]
nun dies ist leider ein so komplexes
trauriges und umfangreiches Thema das
ist weder in diesem Video Platz hätte
noch in einem anderen einzelnen genau
dafür braucht es gleich mehrere Videos
ich werde euch jede verlinken Liebe dazu
schon gedreht haben aber weitere kommen
doch hinzu und keine Angst wir werden
euch das abschreckende Beispiel
Argentiniens wie ein prosperierendes
Land ökonomisch auf die schiefe Bahn
geraten ist und wie eine reiche Nation
sich zurück entwickelt hat ausgiebig
erklären als Lektion und als Warnung
aber jetzt interessiert uns erstmal eure
Meinung glaubt ihr das Argentinien eines
Tages wieder glänzen wird was muss eure
Meinung nach passieren damit der
Wohlstand wieder in dieses Land
zurückkehrt wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt es bei
dein Leid aber mit Glück und keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spenden von euch wenn dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut adios und
bis bald
[Musik]